for hundreds of covid19 patients
plasma therapy could be a lifesaver
patients whose own immune system
struggle to fight the virus
are transfused with antibody rich plasma
from donors who have successfully
recovered
at delhi's loch nayak hospital one of
the biggest
covet 19 health facilities in the
country
plasma therapy has been going on for
months
oversees the essential procedure of
donation
plasma have a lot of protective
antibodies this protective antibodies
present in the plasma
actually kills the virus and helping
eradication of the virus from the
human body and the patient recovers this
is proven but hospitals face
a severe shortage of donors
27 year old panu sharma contracted the
disease while working
in an intensive unit of a kovid 19 ward
i saw how lives were being saved by
plasma therapy
and patients recovered i got inspired i
want my plasma
to save lives
the indian council of medical research
conducted a randomized control
trial study at 39 hospitals across the
country
its findings have not been supportive of
this
treatment there have been the use of
plasma therapy
as i mentioned by the drug controller
has been
an off label of label use but
whatever that was expected has not been
borne out
in this randomized control trial and
that did not show
any benefit in terms of mortality or
progression to severe disease
as far as this study is concerned but
for many like mukesh gomber
believe plasma saved his life
the family had a harrowing time finding
a donor
anguished at their own experience they
with a friend
based in london started a website
connecting beneficiaries
with actually donors that we are not
alone in this there are probably
tens or hundreds of people who were
looking for plasma as well
that's when the idea of don't aim about
but till the time there is a vaccine all
medication is on the table for desperate
families
who believe plasma therapy may just be
that lifeline
never lazarus sky news delhi